the picture isn't quite clear but we
want to show you what we know how we
know it and crucially what we don't know
with Professor Michael Clarke let's
start with this video from the head of
the Wagner forces addressed to president
zielinski he says that they have
surrounded backman as you can see there
can we believe that claim I think we
probably can this time he said these
sort of things before but he's being
very public about this and it is
confirmed by other sources so this time
actually I believe him and was in from
the Ukrainian side this is the commander
of Ukrainian drone unit he's saying they
are leaving the city but we've seen
other posts from Ukrainian forces saying
they're not leaving the city they're
staying how do you reconcile those two
it's that's normal if you're withdrawing
then some troops will stay behind some
troops will be taken out a drone unit
will quite likely be taken out
reasonably early some troops are always
there to to look after the withdrawal so
nobody then they never go all at once
they go in stages and I think that's
probably what we're seeing now and
talking about that looking after the
withdrawal let's show you this video uh
bear in mind this bridge and look
happens to it that looks like a
demolition more than anything I just
want to also highlight one thing here
that building behind it if we can come
and get that up just bear that in mind
but this this video of the demolition
um what does that show us about again
the Ukrainian position yes I mean all
bridges are blown when you're leaving an
area you blow up all the bridges you you
don't do that when you're going forwards
but when you're going backwards you want
to make it as difficult as possible for
the other side to use the facilities so
that's clearly a demolition charge and
it's been pretty efficiently done and we
can be confident we're in the right
location look that does look like the
bridge and also those buildings I
pointed out earlier you can see they are
there in the background so we can be
confident we are in the right location
I'll show you why that matters as well
we can talk about that Michael as well
if we go out of street view and we go
back to the map view this is the Railway
Bridge you can see it there just zoom it
out Zoom it out a bit further and here
we are you can see this is where the
Russian forces are yellow is where they
are claiming to be red is where everyone
sort of agrees they are but you can see
them coming right up to this River why
does that bridge become important in
that context yeah because that's a
north-south railway line and the
Russians would be using that Railway
line if they take it to move heavy stuff
backwards and forwards so the ukrainians
don't want to make it easy for them but
the ukrainians they'll need the the h-32
highway which is this highway the small
Highway that runs Southwest of the city
and that probably is their only real
route out and I suspect we'll see them
taking that route in stages over the
next day or so we have been talking
about banknote for a long time there
won't be a moment this is probably a
process we'll bring the latest in terms
of what we know what we don't know as we
get it